lactis is actually showing up he's gonna
be our new big bad and and because you
need something that Captain Marvel can
kind of have to like fight against and
not be the strongest person in a room I
want the fight that Carol Danvers has
with Thanos to be a rematch to some
earlier even nastier fight Captain
Marvel to is a basically the
introduction Fantastic Four to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe welcome back
to new rock stars this is rogue theory
we're making it happen with the captain
the the other captain we'll get to that
aye aye captain Morgan we are making it
happen that is how we're getting through
this this is another quarantine edition
obviously I'm told Malina going rogue
with us of course and Erik Voss hi
everyone I'm build with cheesecake
welcome back to Tommy Bechtold great to
be here I worked out today
why did you immediately give up on your
life and who do we have with us as the
joven today or Joshua oven Shire we've
got the Shelby Shire of ne6 Fame and
surprisingly I am filled with cake
cheese oh that's the better kind always
trust a man that declares his own Fame
all right speaking of famous heroes that
need some introduction apparently Marvel
introduced their new release schedule
that is all just messed up it's all
pushed back it's backed up it's phase
four is going to be just real late
unfortunately but if you guys notice
they snuck in one more little release
date in there just thinking that we
wouldn't notice something that was
previously unannounced and that's
Captain Marvel 2 is coming in July 2022
just in time for my 23rd birthday
so yeah which by the way like just like
they snuck it in with a bunch of bad
news which was weird in my opinion just
be like and but yeah what the hell is
just throw Captain Marvel to up there I
wonder if it was an accident actually
like you're Sarah
I don't even know anymore all right and
should we like release New Mutants all
right so we now know that the sequel is
definitely happening on a certain date
kind of up but what we don't know
especially with this new timing of all
these releases is how will Captain
Marvel to fit into the phase four of the
MCU what's it gonna be about guys let's
go rogue all right I got a theory so if
you guys remember in Avengers endgame
there is that moment when Captain Marvel
snapped back at Rhodey when he's like
where have you been all this time and
she's like you guys have been saving one
world I've been saving all the other
world so easy I actually think the the
end game take on Captain Marvel was more
entertaining and more true to her
character that I know her ass then the
Captain Marvel movie was a couple months
before that but I think he was a badass
there yeah yeah she and we see how she's
like a team leader and I'm looking
forward to seeing her mixed in with that
ensemble in future team-up movies but
for Captain Marvel - I want to see what
that story was where she saved other
planets in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
I want to see what other world she's
saved and how she was actually playing a
crucial role in the background of the
MCU that we know it has and in recent
videos on the channel I've kind of been
asking like what were the origins of the
Infinity stones how did they get to
where we saw them as in the MCU and
phase one well there's a big question of
like how sano Scott I'll hold it a mind
stone in Loki's scepter when he handed
it off to him I think there's a story
there and I think there's a great
opportunity for Captain Marvel to be
part of that story maybe there's some
interesting like aliens type story right
where you have this like young girl who
needs to be saved and rescued by like
this surrogate mother figure that Carol
Danvers can be the Ripley to the noot of
this girl imagine there's like this
young like korbinite refugee girl who
just needs protection and Carol Danvers
takes her under her wing to get away
from the mad Titan Thanos who now needs
this girl as like
as like the map like maybe in like
Waterworld you know there was a tattoo
map girl on her back anything being a
Waterworld reference to all of this now
it makes sense
time for Waterworld no like imagine this
girl who needs protection Carol Danvers
is gonna protect her in this like
terrifying chase from the mad Titan and
his forces at the like near height of
their power they're still like rising in
power and Carol needs to protect this
girl who has like access or she knows
where the mine stone is and it's gonna
be like this this chase sequence where
they're going world to world and Carol
Danvers has to like protect her world
and all of her people from this mad
Titan Conqueror and maybe at the end of
the movie they relinquished the mine
stone but at least the people are saved
okay uh that's a lot I you know you were
giving me Star Wars vibes at the
beginning just with the idea of Carol
Danvers is out there saving an entire
galaxy or something and she's like your
earth problems are beneath me right now
I'm saving an entire galaxy against the
you know the literal Death Star or
something but then you still gave me
Star Wars Ives when you shrunk the story
down and compared to aliens because I
actually imagine it like Mandalorian
yeah just imagine a moment where Thanos
is walking up to this girl and Carol
Danvers comes out all powered up and
says get away from her you [ __ ] heard
me I said Carol says that a jet that
Thanos was just like this cause Captain
Marvel this have to be another period
piece because if it is technically a
prequel still so does that mean we'll be
getting her wearing like maybe not ac/dc
sure at this time but maybe like I don't
know
three doors down shirt there are no
three doors down shirts you you could
and this could have just Joe Ben's huge
issues that he has with you as a person
I you do a amongst the events of endgame
she could be like having that hologram
call at one point like while like
not from a battle or something and then
eventually there's like this moment
where they really need you on earth
really bad they would they need you to
chop danos his ship in half or whatever
it is that she does and then she you
know has to step away from that so the
movie actually could catch us up before
and then through in the past endgame if
she then has to row back yeah that's
interesting we could see a prequel
history and then that could catch us up
with the concurrent events during the
blip either way I want the fight that
carol danvers has with Thanos to be a
rematch to some earlier even nastier
fight you got a rogue II for a good
amount of this so here you can turn that
into whatever you have on your side oh
you mean sunglasses that I got for free
at a wedding very good there's still
good sunglasses all right and then also
I'm gonna give you a second Rogie but
you know what it does sunglasses already
to things so you don't to make it into
just break it apart again there you go
two rogue E's and this is because you're
doing something that I think is gonna
address an issue with Carol Danvers
she's super overpowered like yes yeah
character is insanely powerful but they
had to keep her out of endgame so that
we had the movie endgame you know what I
mean like I just like reduce it down
where she's just trying to protect one
person one child and maybe there's even
like a whole threat like a John wick
kind of world or somebody's trying to
kill the truck so something that reduces
it a lot smaller to just like this one
thing she has to do and she can't just
Super Saiyan her way through it
exactly it's not about the the bran it's
about the emotions all right tell me
what's your theory
my theory okay so I'm going to first of
all if brie Larson ever put on like a
tight-fitting Goo Goo Dolls shirt I
would have to be put into cryo sleep
because my heart is stopping I'm
isn't it always very close to stopping
whether or not free lotion does anything
I worked out today and that's why it's
very close to stopping you only get so
many beats you don't want to waste them
oh is that true Donald Trump believes
that okay anyway you really I really
pause there for a second and thought
about it and thought about just walking
away from this and starting a new life
anyway Mike you come to borrow a
joven shires brilliant theory from about
a month ago with all I love that
sentence oh it's so good you gave me
goosebumps we tagged the it was the
Heller theory at the end of the movie
there would be a cup oast credit scene
of Nick Fury on the on the sword space
station getting a message home out in
space that there was a team in distress
there's five people five five heat
signatures indicating humans that are in
distress so from there we go and figure
out that those five people are Fantastic
Four and Victor Von Doom obviously and
they're rescued okay so Captain Marvel 2
is a basically the introduction as I've
been trying to introduce for six months
on the show their Fantastic Four into
the Marvel Cinematic Universe so they go
and they rescue them and they're all
obviously shooken up but they haven't
quite you know realize their powers yet
but they do have some bad news
while they were while they were in all
of that peril
they were met with by the Silver Surfer
who was voiced by Jon Hamm Jon Hamm is
voicing the silver sundae in this and he
has some pretty bad news for the people
of earth and that is that Galactus is
coming so what Captain Marvel -
basically does is introduces us to the
Fantastic Four it also brings in
Galactus as the big bad for the new
Marvel movies and we get Jon Hamm doing
the voice of Silver Surfer with Doug
Jones's body work obviously because that
body ain't question anytime soon Tommy I
you oh you're right
this theory gives me the hardest
goosebumps I've ever had but I but it
sounds like a great Fantastic Four movie
what the hell does Carol Danvers do she
just like if she says
hey this guy's coming and he has a
message I think Carol Danvers can be
she's got you know a lot of wisdom and a
lot of now with her memories back
experience and she's also highly
powerful she can kind of help act as
almost like when you go to college
there's the people that help you with
orientation she can be a superhero
orientation guard the Fantastic Four so
she's basically playing the role of
mentor figure to Sue Storm and the
others that's interesting so actually
maybe they don't they don't have their
powers yet until this event happens and
they're in distress and then she's part
of saving them and then she has to walk
them through like hey been there done
that I've been a giant pile of brick
poop yeah yeah this is how you deal with
that absolutely
interesting so it's her movie though so
how does it end up for her what's her
big play I think in the end she kind of
you know I think this is it by the end
of this movie we're gonna have the
silver surfer kind of freed from
Galactus I think she plays the part of
liberating the Silver Surfer first kind
of having to defeat him and then
protecting him for being destroyed by
Galactus since its kind of attached to
my own theory and I'm a little biased I
do like where this is going
I think maybe there should be a little
bit more balance in the sense that maybe
the Fantastic Four get introduced but
now they have to be brought to earth to
be watched over and then that's where we
just see Fantastic Four they get their
cameo and they get introduced and then
you know Joe Carroll has to deal with
like the the real big board Daryl Daryl
Daryl Danvers big changes in this new
movie I know let's put it again it
connects really well to what should
happen in Doctor Strange too so I like
where he's going with this theory it's
based yeah pretty sound logic I would
really like this movie especially if
like the entire time as soon as the
Fantastic Four show up just like Captain
Marvel is framed behind Ben Grimm for
every ankle that they're calling to see
together we can't really see her he's
talking right now you just see like her
like hair go vertical and it Peaks up
over his shoulders that's it yeah that's
it
fantastic
no one Rogge and that becomes and it
becomes my niece yeah and last but not
least a realistic life-size Deadpool
[Laughter]
Tommy I'm sorry I'm gonna need you to
shove all those back into the camera I
want my Road behind me one last time
these are my roadies now all right those
of you that thought like roadies are
just like some cheap block of wood or
something they actually hold to humans
and one metahuman oho when you ready to
bring it home the answer is so
simplistic and easy I'm surprised that
none of you guys have thought of it yet
in fact your movies have been so you
know Captain Marvel centric I think I'm
gonna need to go rogue I'm so used to
doing that and having a sign behind me
movie won't necessarily just be a
Captain Marvel movie much like we saw
with the Captain America 3 which was
Civil War there's a lot of different
people in here now you guys are basing
your ideas on really great theories and
ideas and things that we would want to
see on camera for sure but where I think
we need to look here is some past
interviews and kind of baseless in the
conversations that have already been
taking place we know there's been rumors
and rumblings and some some pitches of a
all-female Avenger style movie well that
goosebump makin scene in Avengers
endgame
all the ladies showed up and targets
like character how you gonna do this on
your own
she's got help we get to see that nice
little 30-second clip into our form all
the ladies of the Marvel Universe
finding their way onto the big screen to
work together in a fun amazing awesome
way like we're getting black widow and
that's gonna be great it's gonna be a
little more than the prequel side of
things yes but is it gonna give that you
know that female lead revolution that we
need in like the big screen superhero
movies because DC already had Wonder
Woman and it took you know Marvel a
little while to finally get there Black
Widow movie up and running but what DC
hasn't done yet and Marvel can get on
the books now is a you know full group
of females I guess then a DC birds of
prey but you know how are we gonna count
that yeah I think is it birds of prey in
the fantabulous emancipation of Captain
ER rule for superhero movies moving
forward that gets rid of you know a
Catwoman steal and birds of prey Joe yes
did you write this theory down and are
you reading it no are you you just have
you have such confidence in you right
now I'm just gonna give you the most
confident delivery of it okay for you
yeah yeah most of my entire career has
been based on a faux confidence so I'll
take it in your your even though we're
talking Marvel and if I can like reach
into the screen here and pull out what I
wrote you it is now a collectible DC
Batman chess piece
there's a whole set of my chess pieces
here so you can you hand that back back
to me this is I I think it changed a
little bit of design but oh man oh okay
there you go now at Nightwing now it's a
high oh it's Nightwing a bishop
Nightwing is uh here's a lady Knight and
uh they really
yeah should've been a night yeah
politics backdoor politics their
backdoor politics
Tommy's political porn site check it out
okay I feel like we interrupted though
so joven I gave you one just by that
confident delivery uh but give us a plot
to this movie right now we just know it
has a lot of women in it I said big
women is we are trying to push a lot of
these stories forward and we don't
technically have another Avengers movie
on the slate we don't really know what
things are gonna look like this kind of
gives us our chance to look at what
there is I also love the idea of
throwing Gamora back into the picture
here because one of the females in that
scene was you know badass Gamora still
in as was it 2014-2015 where she's still
the kind of the bad guy and so we're
gonna see maybe the girls go out and
find her and kind of like not
necessarily rescue her but try to bring
her back to the right side of life uh
and you know III like where Tommy's
going and he pulled a little from my
theory so I'm gonna pull a little from
his theory saying that this is all on
the same copasetic world where Galactus
is actually showing up he's gonna be our
new big bad and and because you need
something that Captain Marvel can kind
of have to like fight against and not be
the strongest person in a room so you
know and all it all works you know it's
all pretty cohesive so we're seeing you
don't get to say it all works we but we
are seeing you know we're Wanda we need
some more Wanda being real Scarlet Witch
here there you're going o P baby because
we're getting some Scarlet Witch
definitely by the end of Wanda vision
we're gonna bow what's like a but I I
need to know a big team up movie like
this now we're talking Avengers level we
have people of all these different
powers and they're up against Galactus
so joven I mean it's just gonna happen
which of them dies ooh which one's gonna
die you know at probably at that point
in time we've probably got us Scarlet
Witch is probably being on camera the
most here so it'll probably be her she
got her TV show she had her time
and it's about the same time we're
introducing you know mutants so maybe
instead of the whole no more mutants
line we actually get her saying more
mutants no more me no more me I know and
then you know whatever way she dyes her
she's so powerful there's no reason why
her magic can't go through and create
x-men in the world
there you go joven that's gonna be she
dies in the movie she whispers something
post credits scene the x-gene awakens
and you just introduced mutants to so
there you go as a second row second row
y'all right guys we pulled that one out
all right now we gotta now we actually
have Batman back sitting next to
Nightwing got just about midnight wig I
urge every challenge you to have no more
Batman figurines for the read so you
made it to eat in yourself alright
alright let's hear them back in a tweet
okay for mine it's going to be two
tweets separately at the same time one
from fan s's account one from Captain
Marvel's account where they both say get
away from her you [ __ ]
and then Captain Marvel's tweets get
more likes
so Thanos just takes us down quietly
just elitist yeah
coward delete his account okay gotcha
I know exactly that film Tommy
Captain Marvel - woohoo and in the
Fantastic Four gimme more
throw in some Galactus send him a pack
to sing send him penguin your best work
yet thank you and jump it ah my
twightwee obviously is brie Larson's
very first tick tock video being shared
to Twitter of her dancing in the Captain
Marvel - outfit to ladies night Wow Oh
gotcha
and then we Eric would do a tweet down
and we find out he would do the dance
uh great all right let us know in the
comments which of these people is right
about what's gonna be Captain Marvel -
and if not right at least which one you
wish would be the next plot for that
movie moving on guys we have as we've
been telling you guys we're playing
rogue theory on our discord
each week we set a prompt and then
we have contestants and they win people
vote which rogue E's they get and then
some judges gets very involved very
complicated but we have our new prompt
was about the strangers things season
for plot and we have our winner to
announce great theories from Danny and
Casey but Danny aka fire killed it had
such a good pitch
basically it picks up where last season
left off where we see hopper is in
Russia and they you know kind of save
the day but then there's a need to go
get hopper from Russia and maybe he's
developed some sort of psychic link he
clearly has some sort of powers maybe
with will and some people know that
needs to go there and so they have to go
through a portal or all of our strange
things kids to get to rush up at the
portal goes through the upside down and
here's my favorite part they finally are
truly forming a gang that is going to do
real life Dungeons and Dragons they each
have their skill sets they each
essentially are encountering like
hostiles and it finally is a full
commitment to the DND world and then on
top of that what they don't know is that
somewhere in that world there is the
main true evil entity of the upside down
that is trying to escape and it's trying
to use one of them as its way out of the
upside down and we don't know who it
currently is inhabiting so kind of a
John Carpenter's The Thing Thing hi guys
it sounded really rogue so Danny great
job on that you're a winner for the week
you guys can play too at home what do
you guys took at that theory by the way
I love it I love John Carpenter's
earthing it's one of my favorite films
and they had a bit of that with Billy in
season 3 when he was like trapped in the
steam room where they were trying to
like force it out of him but yeah to see
that truly applied to each of the
different members of the gang and like
yeah a true D&D adventure in like the
murky foggy upside down like I'd love to
see like more monsters rather than just
like one monster like you could see
different challenges in side quests that
open up right and and they're having to
get there is like an admission right to
get to hopper and try to rescue hopper
maybe he's trying Danny said this maybe
he's trying to also get back toward them
and now he has powers and it simply does
what the first season did really well
give us these characters that we loved a
whole lot of nostalgia the second season
seemed to kind of go in its own
direction and then the third season
brought it all back to the things that
we loved and this theory seems as though
it's gonna give us a lot of things that
we do love already
and still kind of give it a new twist
that keeps us going week two we go
that's that's well thought out yeah I
like it
my only question is are those people who
all melted and formed that joined the
giant monster that was the big bad guy
in season three are they all dead and
gone forever or are they all trapped in
the upside down right now are they also
gonna need rescuing because I think
there's a little bit of like souls lost
to the dark side that'd be really cool
right they could discover a land of
souls basically they need freeing and
they're not necessarily going back to
their bodies but maybe they go into the
afterlife right now they're all trapped
there and they finally see barb yes
there's the justice she's like the
leader of all of them yes action figure
yeah she's got an eyepatch over here
he's got a third eye underneath it just
such a badass now she's talking she put
the same haircut I'm here yeah it's
their crown in there all right guys you
can play rogue theory with everybody on
disk or two and then have us discuss
your theory if you win on here but let's
move on to our second topic and so I
don't know if you guys are keeping up
with Westworld
a lot of people actually had struck a
struggle of following what was happening
in season two of us world with the
mixed-up timeline and season one that's
really cool I thought season two was
very interesting but very challenging
season three is kind of getting to like
the big thing that we always debated is
it you know it's the robots versus the
humans versus humanity who's gonna win
all that stuff so we've got kind of
these champions that are on the show
representing some different sides we
have Dolores and we have Maeve and these
are both hosts who are somehow
representing two different arguments
here so basically I don't want this
segment to only be for people who are
completely caught up on Westworld so
let's make it as simple as this we know
Dolores
basically wants to rule and she she is
representative like the hosts are almost
like the apex predator they're the top
of the food chain and they deserved to
be the ruling class maybe is trying to
stop her so and we'll say she's on the
side of humans we can say that
and then there's maybe other ways that
can turn out so I want you guys to pitch
me who should win like this is the
future we've seen it's 2040 something
things are some things are better some
things are worse if you're being honest
with yourself
should we let robots take over and make
decisions for us to the humans dude good
job is there another way things should
go let's go rogue I got listen the
entire concept of wess world makes me
feel like back when I was in my 20s I
dated an older woman I'm confused all
the time I'm definitely not smart enough
to be in this situation I'm not really
understanding what's going on around me
I wake up every day in the same spot
very confused there's a lot of
repetition I'm giving her vitamins every
morning in the pills that she needs to
survive I just I was 24 she was a
hundred and eight but I and let me tell
you together we made 60 so anyway I'm
team Dolores all the way and let me tell
you why I humbly welcome our Alfa apex
predator Dolores hosts overlords we
can't help ourselves look what happens
when we have autonomy we get Tiger king
people by jungle cats and put them in
their backyard let's have our homework
to keep us safe keep us happy
I don't mind let me back up to the
matrix let me just some sweet sweet
matrix team I know it's a different
property divorce should be in charge
she's the most powerful she has no
emotional reactions I get emotional
about everything like me talking right
now is making me emotional because I'm
remembering being in my 20s and dating
Stella she was so sweet if she lived
through the Great Depression did she
live through the Tommies Depression she
did not see weak unfortunately anyway I
gotta go my god we had to cut that
because Tommy admitted to a crime within
the statute of limitations okay so what
does paint this feature for me go ahead
they
and the robots are the ruling class of
the HOS so what is life like for us I
mean every day we're waking up popping
Chef Boyardee instant microwave will be
furrow knees and it's nonstop and you
want to make the same for you that's
right nothing changes for me problems
drones are dropping them off drones are
letting us know when we have to go do
stuff drones are letting us know what
job we have to do you know how relaxing
it would be for me if I could stop being
ambitious I mean I have zero I have like
11% ambition to like write a script or
go on an audition if I could just lay
back and be a plumber not that there's
anything wrong being plumbers but just
knowing that like I was gonna be a
maintenance man for the rest of my life
God job the peace the sweet release and
peace of that Tommy I just just so you
know because it sounds like it'll bring
you a lot of peace you can choose just
say that but I can't because these are
actually fake phones and they don't
they're not opposable so I only have
four working digits on each hand and you
gotta have five to grab a wrench but
thank you I gotta go check the new
Rockstar HR department the easy number
because I think thanks for taking the
meeting just a quick quick this is gonna
be uncomfortable this is all about you
and so reverse them oh well don't worry
as HR I can separate myself but is it
about your pretty mouth it actually was
it if I get actually just speak to do we
have like an ombudsman or an outside
firm that handles our HR complaints if
it is about a chart Oh Eric yeah yeah
it's me I'll go get him right now one
second I got it hmm hey I'm your outside
HR guy what's your problem great to see
Eric that kind of language is tough to
hear yeah I guess I need to talk to you
about some things that happened on rogue
theory this week you're probably gonna
be able to guess but it is about my
gorgeous succulent mouth and
Philip basically telling me that if it
worked I could make a living well what
about that mouth down in your bottle
does that still work my ass mouth oh
yeah that's fully functional yeah you
guys together okay
and I don't know what it is we have to
talk about wanted to make you aware that
I'm not just a mouth boy anymore I got a
lot more things I can do okay
I can use my thanks are your concerns
Erik the Ombudsman and me will confer
okay I have two minds in my head at the
same time my favorite new rock stars
content we talked
joven you're fired okay yeah my mouth is
not working nor is my self mouth so well
prove to us how bad your mouth is by
giving us a mouth talk about your theory
team robots are team humans the problem
with these two groups here is that we we
don't seem to be noticing something does
it sound like I'm going rogue because
I'm pointing at your wife their wife
dressed up as rogue it's my decapitated
ninja turtle that you can see back there
so I'm not a team aunt or I'm not team
robot or team human in this case because
these robots have something that you
won't normally see in most robots on
film and that's added emotion something
that gets programmed in and emotion as
we can all agree is the biggest flaw of
human beings and you want to give that
to robots as well emotions are a
weakness that slow us down they impair
our judgments I don't want to feel
things I just want to make rational sane
logical decisions so I think I'm gonna
go team AI here because I think we're
gonna see some some you mean like
insight like the the big
Robo home precisely Robo hobo you're
talking about Dolores being kind of like
an apex predator here
no because they've got the biggest human
flaw which is emotion now in Robo home
as we're just gonna call it from now on
they they will take all forms of emotion
and kind of take it out they will be
able to make better decisions better
tactical strategies and be able to
dominate what is left of earth at this
point in time well I'm wondering well no
to be clear that's that's the state that
we found the future and currently right
everybody's choices is pre is pre
decided by this diner computer brain
currently so you think they're doing
pretty well right now yeah it's it's
it's only going to evolve further to the
point where we won't need humans at all
and you know what is that a bad thing is
it
for yeah don't let your emotions get in
the way because that's weakness what
what is the what is the big robot decide
if not the lives of the humans resources
in Java that explodes resources what's
really gonna get it you know it's the
thinnest argument really what we're
gonna really see though is where this
can go is kind of like a Terminator 2
Judgment Day looking to the future where
you got your John Connor but John Connor
is no longer a human it's actually just
emotional robots versus unemotional a
eyes this is an argument that is
different from Tommy's Tommy wants the
host to win you want AI Robo home to to
win yeah all right so both of you are
traitors to our kind and neither of you
is getting a rogue II because I'm human
and I'm a fan of humans uh so Eric I
have I hope you're gonna go the human
argument no I'm also going robots Philip
I'm just kidding
well I'll go robot only in the sense
that I'm on Team Maeve and here's why I
humbly disagree that emotion is a
weakness
I believe that empathy is our greatest
strength and that's what separates me
from Dolores is her capability to have
empathy she had the opportunity to
escape West world in the season 1 finale
and instead she turned back to her
daughter was her daughter just a program
narrative in her mind not a real thing
sure but there's power in believing that
you have an emotional connection with
someone and and I think that's her
attitude toward her daughter defines her
as a character and I think we can all
learn a lesson from that and I think her
capacity for empathy toward the human
race even though right now in season 3
of Westworld she's kind of in a weird
alliance with Ciroc who's also kind of
behind her or her mom I think her
defining moment is gonna be her
separation from anything robot connected
and she's going to align herself with
Caleb who is the first true human on the
show that we have seen he might also be
a robot we all know he said he's have
had a gun pointed out i'ma for he's like
the working man because we've only
encountered people like them from the
dello society and these these people who
are basically the cast of Succession or
something and to have Caleb so you're
kind of like the system should crumble
but be handed over to people like Caleb
yeah and I think maybe isn't one to do
it I think she's the only one who can
truly pose a threat to the threat that
Dolores is bringing and and the
overwhelming threat that insight of
Rehoboam are so I think Dolores can be
the true revolutionary but I want to see
all this technology crumble and be
handed over to the true humans and I
think that by the end of this this
series of Westworld it needs to be a
triumph of the human spirit even if that
human spirit is a ghost and machine of
people like Maeve holy [ __ ] Eric you you
get a silver Rogi for though uh we're
just worth two rogue E's okay I I that
just was so beautiful and nice well on
my end the silver Rogi was a thumb drive
of all of your porn from when we were in
college I have it and why why do you
make it sound like it's like original
creations yeah I'm gonna need
zip drive send ASAP okay here you go
you're gonna need some bleach for your
eyes joven it actually just turned into
uh as I as I reach for it yeah no that's
that's the USB the same exact USB used
oh my god philips porn his college porn
right here you can tell it's porn [ __ ]
cuz the way it expense yeah happy born
alright that was really Pleasant let's
hear back in tweets who's the host with
the most
it's dolores of course yield and bend
your wills to get some thrills with the
host take over the park
it's like Mickey Mouse running Splash
Mountain who would have ever thought
Walt Disney needed to be enslaved by his
creations but that's the case folks
Donald Duck goofy Pluto who knows come
to West world where the host just might
host you that's beautiful i ami you get
I'm running low on things so you get
this Pandora
jewelry box that I've been saving for
someone and that could you know it just
does that jewelry box is expensive so
that's three roadies worth yeah yeah
alright Jobin tweet on the tweet for
this one is uh this tweet has been
brought to you by Twitter this is
Twitter actually tweeting its own tweet
and then Twitter just shuts down yes I
like a literal Angie's Twitter you get a
rug you for that Twitter makes me happy
for like a minute and sad for like 59
minutes it's like okay we got hunters
now uh uh Harrigan here to eat so it's
going to be the tweet is me quote
tweeting saying these violent delights
have violent Lee ended quote tweeting
Caleb saying these violent delights have
finally ended quote 8co tweeting may've
seen these violent lights have violently
ended and quote tweeting what's actually
just a bot who originated that that's
them at explaining the post-credits is
the whole thing it was it was a wake
okay yeah all of this is just my video
explaining the post-credits stated a
really boring way alright Eric uh you
yeah you just get one more note normal
rookie ooh
and it's chapstick you've had chapstick
before and it's a CD from Christopher
James who's got great music
you've been plugging him like crazy I
love his music it's awesome he is good
alright before we go into road questions
let's do a quick recap of a points
because I I'm a little lost
it's an Eric what do you got okay I have
a part of classes and another part of
glasses which you told me were to and
then I have your college porn which you
told me was a silver that's right
actually also I'm ready for the college
porn you're gonna be weeping tears the
whole time it's so beautiful that's
right so I think I have three now got
you three now then could you gave it to
Joe and your silver rose yes what do you
got I'm sitting here with my three
roadies and the this Rogi and also if
you don't give me the victory today this
is going on doing okay okay okay okay
we got five five bro jeez what does the
G stand for it's something different
here and tell me how many do you have
I believe I have one Rogi represented by
my vampire extended family Joshi Allen
Funko which represents silver ovaries
were three so I've got three or four
yeah gotcha all right so it's pretty
close guys either way things are messed
up in the robots approval even though
disagrees with what I said earlier guys
it's time for Road questions it was
announced this week that at the upcoming
Disney attraction Avengers campus
they're gonna serve infinity stone
themed pastries which infinity stone
tastes the best Easi
soul stone
devouring Souls is so delicious plus
it'll look like a strawberry Danish I
mean this is this is a homerun
soul stone I've been eating solstice
legacy of kain Soul Reaver let me tell
you I'd never fill up on them they're
delicious
all right it's all eating great uh I
agree I think that was that time cap ate
the soul stone so he would know how to
taste
I think the mind stone tastes the best
because it tastes like brains which is
some a part of the human anatomy I would
be willing to eat not placenta you would
eat brain yes
I'll put it this way I'll eat brains
before I eat placenta really what if the
placenta contains a brain and a spinal
cord in a fully formed baby Wow I
disagree with your politics life begins
at eating all right and joven with you
ah the best tasting stone also been
opened up at Disneyland is the cold
stone actually you can use from any of
the Infinity stones and they'll match
them together with whatever toppings you
want right in front of you let me serve
to you by stone cold
joven that's a negative to Rogi no joke
there thank you I appreciate that
uh okay all right I'll be uploading this
to my only fans all right up next number
two both Paul Rudd and our DJ Robert
Downey jr. had birthdays this week and
combined they're 106 years old but they
don't look it especially Paul Rudd so
what is the secret trick to staying as
young as these guys do
that's an easy one again you get casted
on Marvel movie they pay you ten million
dollars per movie you are a personal
trainer and the best doctors in the
world who basically microwave your face
once a week to make sure it stays young
forever and they're friends with Gwyneth
Paltrow so you know they're getting gift
baskets from goop on their birthday
that's very that's a double answer to
the answer is simply blood boys in this
particular case when it isn't on camera
he's actually being hooked up to
different IVs having all of his blood
drained
and that blood is then going into Paul
Rudd and our DJ's body he's their blood
boy yes I wish I could be a blood boy
Tommy you have all that extra blood the
angrier Tommy gets the more blood he
builds great and then Eric what he got
I think the secret to their immortality
is they actually died in the 90s and
then Lola VFX has resurrected them on
camera for us oh not bad why did they
die they weren't at fault
I mean drugs abuse drugs all right joven
you definitely get the blood boy Rogge
yes and rody is actually coming out as
this not bad it's a little MORTAL KOMBAT
enamel pin so everybody say it with me
[Music]
and then finally last for a question
Hasbro has released all of the old GI
Joe GI Joe cartoons for free on YouTube
they're still not as good as the
redubbed GI Joe cartoons that you should
definitely look up those are hilarious
but give me your GI Joe character's name
if you're joining that universe in your
GI Joe character voice and you know at
the end of those there's always like the
message to like America kind of like
propaganda cartoons your GI Joe
character and your GI Joe Joe voice give
me a message of hope to America let's
hear hey everybody it's me your friend
bathtub oh you know the guy with a
bathtub on his back like a turtle shell
and remember what bathtub of always says
save water and take a shower with your
horny neighbor bathtub Oh oh my god
shower head bath elbow is not
surprisingly problematic who's next
well you got me here mister
mr. beast allottee and I'm here to tell
you if you got a lovely pet hold them
close and hold them dear cuz you never
know when you're gonna lose them perfect
no no yeah
he also based on the youtuber mr. beast
hugging animals hey kids it's nice stain
you may have seen me helping out Cobra
in the past eighteen minutes but here
I'm telling you that you need to change
your shirt whenever a new day begins be
sometimes food he didn't make it into
your mouth and stain your shirt and
people are gonna know you didn't change
you certain the day before all three of
you get a rocky for each one of those
they were each delightful the bathtub
man was naked yeah mine's a Ralph's
receipt hot toys Darth Maul Japanese art
inspired thanks so much for that one I'm
gonna keep that one here joven this
isn't sponsored okay alright I enjoyed
you guys totals are suppose to remind us
of your total toy for Tommy what do you
got sweet five I got five total so we
got a tithe so then we're gonna do a
quick tiebreaker so one more road
question for you guys you ready mm-hmm
yes so you can we're gonna do this one
at a time so jump and take off your
headphones right Tommy
we're in quarantine life right now I
want you to quickly pitch me who is the
MCU character who would be dominating
quarantine life who would be our king in
this reality all right Nightcrawler he
can teleport anywhere he loves living
alone anyhow and he's afraid that if he
gets too close to people who killed him
so he's social distances naturally
okay but he can't teleport any way we
can teleport like the top of a mountain
or a space real quick and then before he
loses his breath he's our king though
yeah
all right joven we're the same question
to you we're in quarantine time right
now who in marble would
dominating right now in quarantine life
who would be our king or queen whoever's
gonna become quarantine is the one that
can produce the most TP for all the
buttholes around the world and dr.
strange has access to multiple worlds
multiple versus Eric as the impartial
judge who was answer toilet paper joking
wait I did Tommy also give an answer but
no just very good Tommy's answer
immediately killed night crawler by
sending them into space Wow joven you
get a 6 Rogi and you are winner this
week I got Hans lucky dice should have
whip those out earlier German what's
your wish my wish is for the other two
hosts to call out Thanos in a 1980 style
wrestling a stand-up piece on how you're
gonna beat them beat that us in the in
the upcoming Avengers movie Pharos let
me tell you something brother
you think you got all those gems you go
snap snap snapping well I go back all
over you I'm gonna take you down I'm
gonna take you up I'm gonna make you
wish you had no snow no soul no mind no
power no time you're out of time brother
what you're gonna do with a tiger King
go strut it up on you can't you can't
stop licking that ice cream cone and
then you hear the glass shattering sound
effect and stone cold March is dead then
he goes and that's a Braham blah cuz
cold stone gives you some good pastries
guys that's it for this episode of rogue
theory it's ridiculous
thanks so much too hard guess Eric pause
tom expect old and joshua over chars
week's winner very glad to be here it's
always nice when I can steal a win feels
good hey guys please please follow me on
tic toc it Emily Ratajkowski work on
there I don't forget to subscribe to the
podcast feed I stay tuned to the YouTube
channel for this on our other shows and
you guys get it hey you're we're all
nailing it right now positivity up all
the new rock shows on Twitter at new
rock star told me at the melina
instagram twitter i'll see you guys next
time bye
[Music]
you